Transcriptor: Nerea García Garmendia
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Tenemos una relación
complicada con el futuro,
y cuando digo complicada
es tirando a fastidiada.
Para entender el porqué,
necesitamos entender
el momento en el que estamos,
así como algunas cuestiones
antropológicas sobre el futuro.
Vivimos en un momento de gran complejidad,
y cuando digo "complejidad"
me refiero a que está compuesto
de sistemas a su vez complejos,
con múltiples elementos,
algunos de los cuales
no acabamos de entender,
a pesar de los avances
científicos y tecnológicos.
Esto nos genera
una incertidumbre muy elevada.
Podríamos hablar del cambio climático,
o de hecho, deberíamos hablar
de crisis climática,
porque el cambio climático
ya no es una cuestión de futuro,
es una cuestión que
nos estamos comiendo con patatas,
compuesta de sistemas complejos
que aún en parte no se entienden,
y las partes que se entienden
no se sabe exactamente
cuándo acaban de desarrollarse.
Podríamos hablar del auge de las
desigualdades sociales y económicas
y de cómo las economías
globales y los poderes
se están volviendo
a reestructurar ahora mismo.
Por ejemplo, hay algunas empresas
cuyas riquezas y poderes son incluso
mayores que algunos Estados nación.
En definitiva, vivimos en un momento,
y creo que aquí estaremos
más o menos de acuerdo,
que es muy cambiante,
que nos genera mucho desconcierto
en algunos momentos.
Tan es así que en ciencias sociales,
filosofía y estudios culturales,
no hay ningún consenso exactamente para
definir el momento en el que estamos.
Como pueden ver aquí detrás,
hay diferentes nombres,
por ejemplo los "tiempos posnormales",
que en palabras del
prospectivista Ziauddin Sardar,
son aquellos tiempos
en los que las viejas ortodoxias
han muerto
y las nuevas normalidades
todavía no se han conformado.
Nuestra relación con el futuro
cambió hace medio siglo,
y la primera transformación importante
fue hacia el siglo XIX,
cuando la idea de "utopía",
que entonces era un
recurso literario y político
para especular sociedades
posibles y alternativas
respecto a las que
tenían en aquel momento,
podía ser algo realmente creable
por el ser humano,
podía ser construible.
Y el único espacio, no-lugar,
que quedaba disponible era el futuro.
Realmente creían que era posible.
Sin embargo, esta visión optimista
se vio rota hace 50 años,
en torno a los años 60 y 70,
en el momento en que
comenzamos a dudar,
vistos los eventos históricos anteriores,
de si realmente el futuro
podía ser un lugar tan brillante,
tan "brilli-brilli"
como veían los antepasados.
Fue el momento en que empezamos a ver
el futuro como algo oscuro, negro.
No quiero decir con ello que todos
veamos el futuro como algo oscuro,
aunque creo que más o menos algunas
de aquí compartís un poco esa sensación.
Aún convive con nosotros la mirada
de que también el futuro
puede ser brillante.
Es una visión que va conectada con la
idea de que el progreso es inevitable
y que gracias, sobre todo
a la tecnología y la ciencia,
todo tiene que ir, sí o sí, a mejor.
Pero esto significa que
vivimos en un momento
o bien en el que conviven las miradas
optimistas y tecnoutópicas
con la mirada distópica o apocalíptica.
Esto nos lleva a hablar de
una cuestión bastante incómoda.
Y es que el futuro,
entre otras cosas,
es una construcción social,
algo que hemos creado los seres
humanos como un concepto,
sobre todo por las sociedades
contemporáneas y modernas.
Para empezar a entenderlo
podemos destripar los futuros.
Podríamos hablar de
las historias y narrativas.
Otro prospectivista,
por cierto, Estudios de futuro es
una disciplina que lleva oficialmente
más de medio siglo, no es nuevo.
Él estudió diferentes
historias en la cultura popular
para entender este lado,
que también es importante,
y dio con que se podrían resumir
en cuatro arcos narrativos:
Continuidad,
aquello que ocurre cuando tomamos
las tendencias del presente,
tales como tecnológicas, sociales
o culturales del momento
y las extrapolamos de manera simple,
como a veces se hace en algunos medios
de manera recurrente,
y damos este nuevo escenario.
Por eso se llama continuidad.
Muchas cosas cambian
para que nada cambie.
Es lo que en inglés
llaman "business as usual".
Disciplina.
En este caso, hablaríamos
de una sociedad futura
que ha decidido autolimitarse
y autoregularse
mediante nuevas costumbres,
leyes o regímenes,
debido a un desequilibrio interno
que habrían encontrado por el camino,
o por ejemplo, a la falta de recursos.
Declive o colapso.
Tal y como insinúa el nombre,
se trata o bien de
sociedades en degradación
que no han podido contener
esa crisis interna,
o bien que han tenido
algún tipo de catástrofe,
en cuyo caso estaríamos hablando
de sociedades intentando sobrevivir,
o bien que están siendo resilientes.
Finalmente, también hablaba de
las sociedades transformadoras.
Sería un momento en el que
se habría descubierto
algún hallazgo científico o inesperado
que permitiera que las sociedades
tuvieran un crecimiento exponencial.
A todo esto y a otras cosas
le llamamos "imágenes de futuro",
una partícula de análisis muy interesante
incluso para trabajar en especular.
Las imágenes de futuro,
además de estas historias,
también son iconos, arquetipos
o elementos más pequeños
que suelen ser recurrentes
en un colectivo o en la sociedad.
Por ejemplo, los coches voladores,
los rascacielos,
las ciudades supereficientes...
Además, podríamos hablar
de los modelos con los cuales
entendemos el tiempo y los cambios.
El que mucha gente
aún todavía compartimos
es el de la idea lineal de que el tiempo
se desplaza sobre una línea.
Supongo que recordáis
"Regreso al futuro",
cuando Doc marca dónde caerá
el rayo y dice "estamos aquí".
Va ligado de nuevo con el progreso,
con la idea de que el futuro,
en cierto modo está preescrito,
prediseñado y preexiste.
Aquí se interpreta que
el trabajo de un futurista
o incluso un adivinador,
va de adivinar o predecir,
que solo hay una opción ganadora.
O la aciertas o la cagas.
Sin embargo, desde las ciencias sociales,
aparte de los Estudios de futuros,
llevan advirtiendo durante bastantes años
que esta idea del progreso es un mito,
que muchos hechos revelan
que no es una ley natural.
Esto nos lleva a que nos cuestionemos
cómo nos estamos relacionando
con el futuro, en este sentido.
De hecho, en Estudios de futuros
ya estamos trabajando con
la idea de que no existe,
aunque parezca una contradicción.
¿Qué haces trabajando en
futuros si no existen?
Nosotros trabajamos con
la idea de "horizonte".
Analizamos los cambios tal y como
están sucediendo ahora,
desde un pasado
muy lejano o reciente
y tratamos de entender
no solo las probabilidades
con big data y otras cosas,
sino las posibilidades,
porque esto no va de adivinar,
sino de ayudar a prepararnos ante
diferentes contingencias, porque nadie,
ni el big data,
ni ninguna inteligencia artificial,
ni alguien que diga que lo sabe,
nadie sabe qué va a pasar
porque no se puede predecir.
No existe el futuro.
Esto se conecta a su vez con plantear
por qué son importantes
las imágenes de futuro
por tres motivos:
Uno, porque nos influencia
la manera en la que entendemos el tiempo.
Es decir, los humanos
tenemos un problema:
nos cuesta imaginar aquello
que desconocemos por completo.
Para rellenar estos huecos
e intentar hacer interpretaciones,
necesitamos recursos visuales,
conceptuales o incluso recuerdos,
que en cierto modo incluso
son las tendencias:
cosas que ya hemos visto.
Dos, porque por consecuencia
nos ayudan a tomar decisiones,
a valorar, a pensar.
Y tres: en conjunto, esto lleva a decir
que son cuestiones políticas.
Por eso, en realidad, hay diferentes
tipos de miradas de futuro.
Hay política detrás,
porque guarda unos valores,
que indican cómo podría
o debería ser la sociedad,
cómo debería ser el mundo.
Por eso, son cuestiones políticas
y no son una cosa tonta.
Dicho de otro modo,
cómo entendemos el futuro influencia
en cómo concebimos el presente,
y cómo entendemos el presente, a su vez,
influencia en cómo concebimos el futuro.
Si analizamos las imágenes
de futuro de los últimos años,
que pululan en nuestras sociedades,
podríamos ver que es algo así:
O así.
No todas, pero una gran mayoría
de imágenes de futuro
que compartimos todas aquí,
como por ejemplo los robots,
tienen un siglo de antigüedad.
Un siglo.
Es decir, si analizamos
esa sociedad de hace un siglo,
aunque vengamos de ahí,
era una sociedad distinta,
con culturas diferentes,
con valores distintos,
con otras necesidades
y otras realidades,
y seguimos tomándolo de referencia.
Por eso, estamos en un momento
en el que necesitamos
nuevas formas de relacionarnos
con el futuro y el contexto de cambios,
con el concepto de la Teoría de cambios.
Necesitamos nuevas maneras,
nuevas metodologías y nuevos imaginarios.
Necesitamos nuevas formas
que nos ayuden a lidiar
con el elemento "What the Fuck",
esta sensación que nos genera
de "¿qué está pasando?".
¿Quién habría dicho hace nueve años
que miles y miles de personas
habrían salido a la calle,
habrían acampado y empezado
a tomar decisiones
y debatido sobre qué modelos
de política querían.
Bajo movimientos
en diversos puntos del mundo,
como el 15-M, Occupy [Wall Street]
o la Primavera Árabe.
¿O quién habría dicho,
hace menos de dos años
que los osos polares,
que son animales solitarios de por sí,
habrían cambiado sus patrones y
se habrían movido cientos de kilómetros
respecto a su zona de origen,
para encontrar otros tipos de
alimentos a los que, hasta entonces,
no les habían hecho tanto caso.
En este caso, se supo que los osos
saquearon los vertederos
de algunos pueblos de Siberia.
Esto ocurrió a principios de año
y otra vez hace relativamente poco.
En resumen, en este momento
necesitamos nuevas miradas,
animarnos a tener
incluso diferentes perspectivas,
como una caja de herramientas.
Necesitamos incluso escuchar
algunas voces que,
aunque no las hayamos oído,
llevan años teniendo otra
relación distinta con el futuro,
que estarían en lo que llamamos
"márgenes culturales",
como los afrofuturismos,
o la ciencia ficción feminista,
o las posthumanidades críticas.
Estamos en un momento
en el que, como veis,
necesitamos replantearnos seriamente
nuestra relación con el futuro.
Tenemos que hablar.
Desde aquí, me encantaría
proponeros abrir la mirada,
no encerrarnos en una sola creencia
sobre cómo es el tiempo,
porque nadie lo sabe, ni la Física.
Relacionarnos de nuevas maneras,
romper con algunos
estereotipos de futuro
que no son promesas
que se tienen que cumplir,
sino que las podemos dejar.
En definitiva, necesitamos
nuevas imágenes de futuro.
Necesitamos menos "The future is now",
que es muy derrotista,
como si no hubiera nada más por hacer,
que ya nos podemos ir a casa a dormir.
No, el futuro siempre estará
después del presente.
Por eso, necesitamos menos
"The Future is now"
y más futuros que nos provoquen "Guau".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)